I realized I was thinking about a
Michael I'm getting ready to talk to you
and I'm like I think I started
interviewing you in like oh eight or
only money and I'm like Yellow
Handkerchief oh wow and it was like yeah
I've been doing this a long time and you
have to yes that is true
jumping in do I get to talk to you I
just want to thank you for reminding me
why I'm never going in the ocean again
hey my same straight up yeah um can you
actually like are you a fan of going in
the ocean or can you go swimming or not
at all um I don't like saying no to
stuff
I'm very sort of like easily persuaded
but I am NOT a swimmer and I am NOT like
a huge beach person like it's like sand
in the Sun and it's dirty and I get
burned and I'm like I always hurt myself
at the beach somehow like no matter what
at the end of the day I like definitely
crashed and burned at some point or got
like pummeled by a wave or something and
I'm like man I don't want to go to beach
anymore so no definitely not I'm the
worst person to have been cast in this
movie one of these things I'm watching
the movie and I'm like the thing I dig
about this is that it wastes no time
jumping in it is like two seconds after
this movie starts you are racing from
just trying to survive could you talk
was that one of the things that drew you
to the script yeah I thought um to be
sort of like completely caught unawares
and like just that like ultimate
nightmare scenario of brushing your
teeth you're like kind of essentially
like in your underwear and and and the
world blows up around you is like that's
kind of the worst case scenario and the
characters initially are so sort of
roughly drawn you just wonder about them
and the whole time I was reading Nora
initially in the scripts like 20 pages
in before it actually started to finally
develop I was like there's something
delicate about her there's like
something wrong because she doesn't have
basic survive she has basic survival
instincts but she doesn't have like the
obvious sort of like reaction to trauma
where she's asking questions like why
did this happen
or like what where is everyone oh I want
to be maybe we can reach the surface I
want to talk to a loved one it's like
very sort of like she doesn't really
know what she's fighting for
and so I was like there's clearly
something wrong here and halfway through
the script I was like oh there is
something very wrong and you come to
find that out but I just thought it was
interesting to have somebody who like is
supposed to be the hero of the story not
have any reason to be the hero you know
what I mean like usually there's
something to fight against something to
hold on to something to retain in her
case like not at all it was just like
super kind of weird existential
fundamental last-ditch effort at
connection that kind of pulled through
and surprised even her yeah I also
appreciated that no one in the film is
trying to sleep with each other yes
there is no time no time maybe if there
was less time somebody would have [ __ ]
right exactly maybe like that 20-minute
intro look we're all dead anyway okay I
was reading that you might be directing
something soon writing and directing
something soon is that happening yeah
I'm like gunning to finish this first
draft to actually send it out to like
financers and like potential actors
before I go make this next movie that
I'm going to do in the coming weeks so
it's like my last film as an actor
before I stopped taking jobs in order to
make sure that I actually see this to
you know at the end so yeah I'm working
on it I know I have to go but do you
mind like sharing do you is there like a
log line or a synopsis or something you
can say about it well it's based on one
of my favorite pieces of writing that
exists so if you're like really curious
about it I would say definitely go read
the chronology of water it's available
thank you so much for your time and
congrats on this job thank you